the studio behind classics like  half-life and left4dead  is added again with new virtual reality  games I'm Tony this is a GameSpot news  update and be sure to subscribe to keep  up with all the latest VR news valve is  already ventured into VR with the lab a  brief experience for the HTC vive but  now it's working on three quote full  games it's not clear what these projects  are but valve has already sprinkled VR  on to some of its other properties  president Gabe Newell has mentioned that  the team has working VR builds for  half-life 2 and Team Fortress but those  aren't intended for public release we'll  just have to see what valve does next  as with any valve announcement expect  plenty of internet comments asking about  half-life 3  sorry no mention of that here but in the  meantime you can check out our HTC vive  review the headset valve helped develop  and to keep up with all the latest from  the studio you're already in the right  place